[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
welcome to culinary genius
today's cooks face two high-pressure
battles and later superstar chef Gordon
Ramsay will be on hand to give them some
inspiration now today's contenders have
each brought an item from home which
they hope will help them compete now
providing quality control is a fantastic
chef from the South Edward Lee from
these fantastic oh boy cooks we have
here today we have a tough fish prep
challenge for the three survivors who
make it to the final cook-off I have a
super fresh pantry of Asian
Mediterranean and tex-mex inspired
ingredients well in round one our
contestants will have their filleting
skills put to the test and at the end of
the battle two will be heading home
so let's reveal today's ingredient
contestants please lift your cloches
it's salmon before Edward sets the first
challenge here is legendary chef Gordon
Ramsay on how to get the best from this
king of oily fish right today you're
getting to work with this beauty this is
the king of the sea incredible fresh
wild salmon now whether you're poaching
grilling trust me is incredibly
delicious it's healthy is packed with
protein and omega-3 now when buying
fresh salmon make sure the flesh is firm
the eyes and the gills are bright what
would I do with this today I'd turn this
into the most amazing hot smoked salmon
serves over a bed of warm potato salad
so Edward what's the first challenge for
our talented cooks today thanks Gordon
today Cook's I want you to fillet a
whole salmon into ten equal portions so
the first thing I do is I take that
first fin I'm gonna go behind that
collar and I'm going to make a small
incision lift the fin go right under
there always move the fish towards your
hand don't move your hand towards the
fish what I'm gonna do is take this
knife and just the tip of the knife goes
in and we're going to follow that bone
okay now peel back the flesh a little
bit and we're gonna run that knife along
the bone here
angle that knife just a tiny bit down
what you're trying to do is leave as
little flesh on the bone as possible
this opens right up okay now I want to
release that I'm gonna come right back
this way turn my fish back and I can
take my boning knife at this point and
and just come right across here just a
very gentle sawing motion when you get
to the tail just clip it right off your
fish should release perfectly right off
there we're gonna go for the next side
all right so you're gonna take your
knife you're gonna go underneath the
meat is staying on the filet not on the
bone very good now we're gonna start
cleaning this fish so you want to make a
nice beautiful shape trim that out I
want five even pieces out of here one
two three four and the last piece five
if I were to put this on the scale they
should all the way the same amount back
to your stations let's do this
contestants you have ten minutes on the
clock
filleting knives at the ready let the
battle begin
filleting does not look easy but why is
it a good thing to do the key thing is
freshness that is the most important
thing about fish they buy a whole fish
you know all those gorgeous nutrients
and all that flavor is still in there
filet it yourself and you're guaranteed
a fresh piece of fish all right well
let's see how they're doing on the
figure how do you feel you're doing so
far little bit listen do percent support
that's getting delicate
this is not a piece of meat go with
small incisions because if you make a
mistake you can always recover how is
the knife skills going they're very
interesting
okay very interesting you keep twisting
that fish important thing should I need
fillets on that boards do it however way
you need to okay all right all right how
you doing I'm doing all right
oh good smiling you see me you seem
positive and you're having cherry sauce
here is it good with that you feel go
nicely with this if you make it through
the next round I think I'm with you
good good marinade for the fish listen
you're doing a pretty good job okay keep
it going nice surgical we're at the
halfway mark cooks the halfway mark
hello Jabbar hello you're manhandling
that salmon a little bit poor salmon
it's okay it's okay
yeah don't hate me too much so I'm sorry
yeah I see a lot of flesh on those bones
yes so I want to see them beautiful and
let's go
all right Suzanne how you find the
challenge challenging tell me good have
you ever done this before never never
for someone who's never done it before
you've got one fillet down
I think everyone's having both at a
difficulty with this fish yeah
everyone's kind of going in there and
and they're just kind of sawing at the
fish
I think Eileen is was just a little bit
tentative and she needs to just be
confident and just make nice swooping
simple small incision mark needs to stop
dancing around with the fish keep it on
the cutting board and start filleting it
he's got a pretty good start he just
needs to keep on going you know what
Magnum is doing pretty good
she had that first fillet down she's
cutting it nice and smooth it looks
beautiful she's going very slowly so I
just want to make sure she has enough
time to finish one final minute to go
Devon is working quickly but a little
bit messy so I want to make sure that
fish is really nice you know Susan
hurtfully was really tiny it's about
keeping the flesh on the fish not on the
bones just get it on that
[Music]
[Applause]
we have the time to impress Edward with
their filleting skills but only three
can make it through to the final round
let's go ahead and start with you Eileen
I think you ran out of time with these
guys and you kind of messed up over here
these five are absolutely gorgeous
[Music]
my goodness your salmon looks like
they've got to a fight with a shark your
meat over here is just looking like
chopped liver
have you done this before not on a fish
this big okay that was a really nice
really nice look at that perfect
this is fish you can work with you just
need it to trim them off better than
this but a bit of time yeah yeah yeah
it's not bad it's a little bit sloppy
and you need more time to just make it
pretty but the essentials you kind of
got so not bad thank you you got your
fish on the board however you only have
eight Suzanne I could feed a family of
four with the fish that you left on this
bone okay all right no it's a tough
first round indeed but now it is time
for Edward of course to tell us who has
made it through to the cook-off
[Music]
the first contestant going through to
the final is Maggie
[Music]
second contestant to go through is
Eileen the third and final contestant to
go through to the cook-off is
[Applause]
now you Eileen and Jeff are you are
going through to the finals that means
of course we have to say goodbye to mark
and Suzanne so thank you for being a fun
part of a today's show our three
finalists must now produce a dish of the
highest quality using the salmon that
they have already prepared so chef what
are you looking for from our three
finalists you have to be more creative
than the person standing next to you
make sure the presentation is delicious
and pretty to look at now you have just
two minutes to grab as many ingredients
as you want the time starts now chef
what do we have in the pantry today we
have everything from fennel to
watercress there's lemongrass and there
beautiful lemongrass
there's juniper berries you can do
things with miso pine nuts maple syrup
and even tequila oh I see some stuff
that I start grabbing and I had two
different directions I was going to go
but I just kind of just grabbed
everything just one minute left we're
halfway through
one minute left contestants there's so
many good ingredients automatically my
brain just had an overload of ideas of
what to make remember this is your one
trip to the pantry get everything you
need the pantry is closed now you have
25 minutes to create a ps/2 resistance
that could lead you to culinary glory so
let the battle begin
hello Eileen we're stepping in to find
out what you grabbed for the pantry I'm
gonna roast some Tomatoes puree as well
I have a lot of ingredients and I have
to distribute Maggie what did you grab I
grabbed a lot of different veggies and
citrus fruits so I'm gonna be marinating
the salmon in the chimichurri good luck
Jabar salmon and you and not a pairing
that you usually see no not at all no
absolutely not
what's wrong fish I've grown up I've
never liked sea foods Wow yep this is my
first time I've ever cooked fish like I
had nightmares that would be the main
ingredient but I mean flavors are
flavors so I can try to just do the best
I can
Jabar where did you grab from our pantry
my I grabbed a maple syrup some wine
some chilies mushrooms and grits and
couscous as well I saw grits which I
love to cook with so I'm a southern boy
my family's from originally from
Mississippi so okay I don't know just go
back to my Southern heritage I guess and
deals do something with the grits I have
faith in you chef gorgeous pantry
options today what would you have chosen
and what would you make all right so I
see some chanterelle mushrooms and
tomatoes beautiful char all those
vegetables roast them on the side get
that skin really crispy and then really
nice butter
lots of lemon lots of citrus pour that
right over the fish
aggi is making a chimichurri marinated
salmon that chimichurri she brought from
home when I'm worried about with Maggie
is that I don't want that salmon
overcooked the worst thing it's like
overcooked salmon with chimichurri
Javaris never cooked salmon his life now
he's going to Trump a spicy salmon with
grits and roasted vegetables trying
something for the first time especially
under this kind of pressure it can lead
to mistakes
however sure VARs from the South I'm
from the South you put anything with
grits and some spice on it it's gonna be
good
i Lena's making a Mediterranean style
baked salmon she's got a ton of
ingredients on her board she might get a
little confused
we're in 15 minutes cooks 15 minutes
remain halfway through the final battle
three salmon are being prepped and
garnished as our contestants go flat out
to finish their dishes now Maggie
yes you've had a wonderful opportunity
to really travel around the world how
much is that influenced your cooking
style
everywhere you go you try new incredible
food so it kind of comes out when you
when you're cooking and what do you
usually cook for for my husband and my
family and I have a dog as well and I
cook biscuits for him oh good doggie
nomadic1 lucky dog what would it mean to
you to be able to win the title of
culinary genius it means I can probably
travel a little bit more well you
continue on a great start to your meal I
can't wait to taste evening your
heritage and your cooking style we
actually cook a lot of techniques food
at home but going up we also had
avvocato with our foods because my dad's
whatever this first Jobs was a Mexican
chef in Canada oh it's really eclectic
my cooking style a lot different kind of
flavors and you have some of your family
in the audience today who's here for you
my sister's in the audience
what is your favorite dish that she
makes Chinese steamed buns with roast
pork in it so that was delicious
delicious well I'm gonna leave you to it
great going thank you good start cook
seven minutes remain he's really putting
in that much sugar in his grits that's
not gonna work at all Bar tell me a
little bit about growing up with soul
food both my grandmother's were cooks
cooking Mississippi so I learned
watching them growing up in the kitchen
maple syrup from the grit don't judge me
never I would never who's the
beneficiary of all these goodies you're
making in the kitchen my husband of
three years he's I get to cook for him
cuz he turns water so do you really burn
water I am at like a horrendous cook how
lucky do you feel that you have Jabbar
who can actually cook a fantastic meal
in your home it's incredible he would
starve otherwise being named culinary
genius yeah what would that mean to you
I mean I've been cooking my brother is a
chef actually oh wow once he graduated
clearing school he went to the army and
decide to serve the US this is something
that I know his dream to do something
like this I'm here living his dream for
him I mean a lot to me so this is for
your brother yeah absolutely all right
well good luck thank you
five minutes left we have five minutes
all right Maggie whoo so you love the
color green don't you I do okay Green
Green Green Green Green is this your
salmon yes okay Wow I'm concerned about
this salmon just because there's so much
going on I think a few pieces of my
salmon got quite burnt everything can be
delicious but if your salmon it's not
guess what you're at okay good luck
thank you to come what's going on I need
to see some energy what's going on do
you think your so you don't have to
break a sweat I'm actually freaking out
inside
25 minutes not a lot of time to cook a
dish how are you cooking your salmon
it's in the oven right now did you pick
the best fillets I did I did you make an
extra one just in case all right listen
2 minutes left everyone beautiful plates
think about are you tasting things as
you go I've never cooked salmon before
so taste it make sure you have the
perfect thing I taste it the flavors
seem to be there hopefully they work
well together all right we'll see you a
little bit
what do you think about Maggie Maggie's
food looks vibrant it's just got the
beautiful chimichurri some beautiful
vegetables going so everything's gonna
rest on that Salmons life I'm gonna have
some wonderfully spicy salmon from devar
he knows what he's doing is confident he
can pull it off man it'd be great 30
seconds just 30 seconds think artistic
[Music]
to the final part of culinary genius
where it is time for Edward to judge our
cooks salmon creations I think that I've
done as much as I could I'm really
hoping that she actually loves it it's
what I wanted it to be it looks vibrant
I think that the chimichurri will really
stand out so I'm really happy I feel
confident in the flavors I don't have a
presentation
what I love about this plant is refined
it's elegant its delicate but that
salmon is puny all your size are kind of
overcrowding this really delicate piece
of salmon it's a little bit overcooked
okay you got a lot of flavors going on
in this plate salmon is really delicate
the fennel salad with the orange is
beautiful couscous nice the asparagus
works that tomato it just kind of
overpowers the fish overall though I'm
really impressed this was a beautiful
plate of food I love the vibrant colors
I love the flavors I love the green
going on here I love that chimichurri
sort of around the side very nice
looking plate you seriously charred that
salmon which is good because you want
that crispy salmon skin but you also
want that beautiful flesh on plot okay
well you managed to cook a nice piece of
salmon I know you used the chimichurri
on this you could have put even more on
there well then I would eat that any day
at a restaurant
look at this balancing act of asparagus
that's pretty cool all right
Oh sassy chef would you have some water
what am i doing that's like candy what
you're putting those grits a little
butter a little sugar and just a touch
of maple syrup I'm feeling you put a lot
of sugar yeah I was trying to balance
its spiciness little sweetness spicy and
sweet aren't gonna balance each other
out okay they're gonna sort of magnify
it each other this is the first time you
cook salmon yeah all right I'm gonna
tell you that salmon is delicious it's
really really well done love the hit of
spice on there your salmon is delicious
everything else is kind of atrocious so
you have this thing where I was
expecting the salmon to suck but it's
gorgeous
and I was expecting the grits to be
delicious and it's not you should be
proud that Salmons delicious so listen
for first time I'll take it all right
all right our three finalists have
really given it their all and Edward has
decided on who impressed him the very
most
[Music]
finalist please lift your cloches it's
screams summer because vibrant listen it
was a beautiful this
you
you